do I look like a Russian spy bang bang
what we should have done is kick Russia
off the international banking system I
don't think Vladimir Putin is a killer I
think he's a serial killer honorable was
genocide and what's happening now is
genocide and we've got to say to the
Russians they would tie people behind
their backs put the gas mask on the face
is being paid for in Ukrainian blood and
that is a disgrace and a shame Ukraine
has to fight because if it doesn't fight
it's there's no Ukraine
hello my name is Julia timoshenko and
this is Ukraine Through The Eyes of
reporters a series of interviews where
we talk to foreign journalists about
their experience of covering the war in
Ukraine if you find this video
informative please subscribe to our
Channel and share the story on your
social media as well as check out more
stories at the Ukraine or website and
today our guest is John Sweeney a
British writer reporter formerly
investigative journalist at BBC covering
Russian war against Ukraine John a
nearby description on patreon you say
what gets me out of the pub is when
power and money say to Ordinary People
you shut up could you tell us more about
that and about your journalistic career
in general well in very simple terms
um I first called Vladimir Putin a war
criminal 23 years ago when I went on the
cover to church now and I saw compelling
evidence of the Russian army killing
refugees and that's a war crime and I
saw compelling evidence of them using
fuel air bombs against civilians and
that's a war crime and using torture on
a massive scale and that's a war crime
too I wrote the story over my then
newspaper The Observer
um calling Vladimir Putin was a war
criminal and no one listened to me
so in a kind of Bonkers way Julia this
is kind of therapy for me that's like
it's I know there's an awful bloody war
but at least I said listen I told you
he's a war criminal and no one listened
and for far too long the West
backed away from standing up the
Vladimir Putin because we were greedy
because we were cowardly because we were
stupid
and what is beautiful about being for
example in key for the Battle of Kiev
and I never left was the sense that
Ukraine
Ukraine has to fight because if it
doesn't fight it's there's no Ukraine
it's an existential fight for Ukraine
but also this for me is simple this is a
war of good versus evil now yes it's you
know it's Ukraine perfect no of course
not you know am I perfect I'm not
perfect but it is was a peaceful
democracy in 2014 and then the Russians
invaded and then the Russians have
invaded all over again
February 24th last year this was a
country a democracy at peace and then
Russia comes in and then when you see it
and I've just been on a trip down to the
back area and then down to make alive
Anderson
there's just part of me Julia goes what
the [__] are they doing I'm allowed to
swear I'm gonna swear anyway it's okay
okay but what the [__] are they doing
what are they what do the Russian people
think they're doing what what what
what's going on inside Putin's head
I don't understand it but I do
understand the ukrainians
must fight and Elon Musk
who is a fool
um has written I mean I read it this
morning on Twitter he says you know the
diplomats won't War while the Warriors
won peace are you having a laugh hello
myself you can see how muddy these
trousers are and then I've got a spare
pair of trousers but somebody's
Nick I can't find my spare part of
trousers so at the moment I'm stuck with
these and I they're muddy because I hung
out with Ukrainian artillery firing
shells in the Battle of Batman and it
was very noisy and very muddy but I
asked one of the guys one of the
artillery people who spoke English why
are you fighting we're fighting with we
have to huge bang okay
we're fighting because of the terrorists
and really Elon Musk you know don't take
it from me go and go to the Battle of
Batman and talk to the Ukrainian
soldiers talk to everybody here
it's kind of the thing is it's desperate
it's brutal it's grisly it's cruel the
war is horrible
but Ukraine's fight Ukraine's spirit is
a thing of beauty
through beautiful words and yeah thank
you it's really Pleasant for me as a
Ukrainian to hear that perspective from
somebody who's an outsider but sort of
spend so much time during the most
horrific time of our history with us
um I want to go back a little bit to
what you said about uh just the West
being foolish and not listening to
people like you not listening to
ukrainians who also and other
formerly occupied Nations formerly
occupied by Russia about the fact that
Putin is just like any of them just the
next dictator that he's dangerous and
that has been ignored then
um he invaded chechnya and Georgia then
Ukraine in 2014 when it comes to
governments I mean there's a lot of
times ties I know that you've been also
doing some work exposing those types of
different politicians to uh the Kremlin
but what surprises me
um I guess why journalists weren't as
interested as you and your profession uh
there was a kind of
a mind thing a group think
the Putin was too big
um and the story was too complicated but
also there wasn't the other thing was I
went to church undercover twice in 2000
and I reported on the the um the latter
part of the second church and War
and that was started by Vladimir Putin
his case was ballet his reason for the
war was because of a church and
terrorist attack in Moscow in the Moscow
apartment bombs and then if you
investigate it it's very simple the
Moscow apartment bombs planted by church
and terrorists were planted by the KGB
FSB now you're nodding because you're
Ukrainian and So like
um but I wrote about this in my book
killer in the Kremlin so the big killing
starts the moment Brotherman Putin is
yeltsin's prime minister and he starts
essentially by blowing up Russia
and we knew that
we knew that because I wrote the story
in my newspaper The Observer so as well
as calling him a war criminal I also put
in the story about the ryzan sugar the
bomb that didn't go off and all the
evidence the the series of bombs were a
um a black operation by the KGB FSB
if you I love the detail of this there
was the one that went off in the
southern city of Volga domsk and the pro
Putin speaker of the Russian Duma there
uh their Parliament
um said there's a bomb that's gone off
the Volga donk
he was right
but the bomb didn't go off when he
announced it it went off three days
later
no I'm a yeah
um very boring
um but I like facts and evidence and I
don't think people are psychic I think
that's all [__]
so what's the explanation how does the
speaker of the Doomer who is one of
Putin's people how does he know a bomb
is going to go off and volca dance
because he knew inside information
and he they got the date wrong
but the place on the money
so Putin's war crimes start there and I
think MI6 and the CIA knew all about it
one of the reasons I say this is because
my friend Christopher Steele who is the
former MI6 officer who was the head of
the uh the Russia House the Russian
department at MI6 British intelligence
has told me so
he was the man by the way who wrote the
report on Trump being sexually
compromised by the the Russian secret
State and Christopher and I believe and
lots of other people believe
the Putin's original sin was the blowing
up of the Moscow apartment bonds
the reason why the West looked the other
way was because of 9 11. so 9 11 happens
um you know 2001 and then suddenly the
West
has a terrible fear of the radical Islam
of islamism both
in Afghanistan which was the place where
the attack on New York was planned but
also Muslims in our own countries in the
West
I believe that this fear was
this fear is real but it was too
paranoid and overblown
and our real danger isn't with
um islamist uh Terror cells Terror units
islamist
um terrorists but with
nuclear armed Terror
Vladimir Putin's regime
and so what happened was for far too
long
we were terrified about a danger a real
danger I'm not dismissing the day I've
been rocketed by the Taliban nine times
in Pakistan so I'm fully aware of what
it's like but at the same time
the far greater danger to world peace
and to Western Security
comes from Russia and behind Russians
China but the fundamental mistake we
made the West made was by over
um fearing islamism radical Islam and
under fearing Vladimir Putin's fascist
Russia
but for heck's sake there are three
moments like I'm British if you're so my
great friend Jessica Berlin who you
should interview
um she can do this very well so we
whenever we meet we have an argument and
almost a fistfight about who's worse
Britain or Germany
um but my argument would be Germany
wanted Russian oil and gas on the cheap
but what Britain did was Britain created
London grad which is essentially
the washing machine for dirty Russian
money so money comes out of Moscow it's
dirty and it gets washed in London grad
and one of the things I want to do is to
burn down London Gray
there are free Moments Hello by the way
um this is just therapy you're like a
psychiatrist for me it's just sort of
sitting there agreeing with me it's but
there are three moments where we should
have really said to Vladimir Putin stop
this because he's behaving like a school
bully the first moment was the poisoning
of Alexander lip bananco former KGB
Spike but at that point a British
citizen
with polonium 210.
I did a panorama about it and I wandered
around Moscow and St Petersburg saying I
have a question
can you buy polonium 210 in a shop
the answer is no
the point of the question is no you
can't buy it in a shop it's made by the
the Russian States and it's very it's a
very very expensive poison after lip
balenko was killed Britain kicked out
four Russian diplomats that's pathetic
it's nothing all that Putin has to do is
press print on his diplomatic passport
machine four times print print
four new passports four rotten spies go
and spy in the London Embassy he doesn't
give a damn
the second moment is the shooting down
of mh17 now yes the invasion of Crimea
um was wrong and against international
law and the invasion of then that's
going against against international law
and the first
rip it's The Ripping up of the post 1945
settlement and we should have reacted
more heavily against that but when that
plane was shot down 298 people were
killed and there were 10 britons on
board that plane
and again it was it was
we let Putin get away with it we let
Putin get away with murder I went to the
crash site Panorama I
um interviewed two ukrainians who had
met a Russian office um with the book
missile traveling on a Jeep behind he
spoke Russian with a Moscow accent it
was the Russian army book missile it was
a Russian missile that killed those
people it took them almost 90 years too
yeah to finish the investigation and the
reason was because
people didn't want to lose dirty Russian
money in London and the Germans Etc
didn't want to lose cheap Russian gas
but time and time again then the third
thing is the the scribble poisonings the
Salisbury poisonings
they tried to kill
Sergey scripple for my Gru spy his
daughter they survived but they did kill
a completely innocent British citizen
Dawn Sturgis this time we kicked out 120
passports around the world so um
diplomats around the world again all
that Putin does is press play you know
press Flint Prince on his machine
he doesn't care we're losing real
British lives
and he's printing new diplomatic
passports we're losing our blood blood
of our people he's playing with Monopoly
money he doesn't care it's a game to him
what we should have done is kick Russia
off the international banking system
wait earlier and we didn't and the price
of our Folly is being paid for in
Ukrainian blood and that is a disgrace
and a shame
yeah that's a
it's a one way to summarize summarize it
definitely
what was your first experience of coming
into Ukraine I first came to Ukraine
um in 2011 when I made a a radio
documentary about the holiday War
I went to the London School of Economics
which was founded by the webs and George
Bernard Shaw and one of my favorite
places at lse London School of Economics
was a um The Shaw Library where you
beautiful library and you sat in lovely
comfy chairs and read books and I love
that place but George Bernard Shaw was
an idiot who denied the Hollander more
and I became fascinated with the idea of
a clever man who wrote wonderful plays
he wrote the Pygmalion which became the
musical My Fair Lady which I love when
I'm playing in in school
um Colonel Higgins I sang terribly but
why is this clever man talking such
rubbish because the holiday mall was
real and I did a radio documentary about
the holiday more and I can remember
talking to a very elderly Ukrainian
woman who remembered
starving as a child and when she saw
African kids starving with the distended
bellies he said I felt so sorry for them
because I can remember when I was like
that too
and this story Malcolm muggeridge was a
hero of mine he was one of the three
Great Western journalists who told the
truth Walter Duran to the New York Times
lied and it's a continuing disgrace for
the New York holds that Pulitzer Prize
put it in the bin New York Times because
you are honoring a man who is
effectively a man who who helped lie
about Stalin's crimes against humanity
Malcolm muggeridge
um wrote that this was a crime so
monstrous no one in the future will ever
believe it happened and that's why I
made this radio documentary called
useful idiots and then that led me to
write a thriller called the useful idiot
none of these books are in Ukrainian
sadly but um if somebody Ukrainian
publisher wants to publish it I'd love
it but the useful idiot looks at the
store of Gareth Jones which you know
who's a great Welsh hero and and I met I
met his niece who's dead now but I met
Gareth Jones's niece when she was still
alive and she's in my radio documentary
I'm divorced now but we're still pal I'm
still part of my um my wife my second
wife
um but for some crazy reason
I don't like New Year's Eve
um I think it's a bit it's Joy at a
moment in time I don't like it and so we
have a hat we had a thing about going to
Crazy places one Year's Eve we went to
Beirut
another New Year's Eve we went to the
next
the airport was beautiful the city was
beautiful and and then in 2014 I saw it
so I've I've got a sense of it so
and then this get anyway this is how I
love Ukraine so Bonkers I don't know if
you know you should look it up you have
a clip of it but I did a panorama about
the Church of Scientology Julia are you
a member of the Church of Scientology
correct answer
they say that I'm a bigger an alcoholic
and I am psychotic I'm sure that's true
but they are an evil space alien cult
that preys on people and mentally
kidnaps their victims I say we had a we
did a panorama at one point they
maddened me so much I lose my temper and
it goes out on YouTube
uh the result was that five million
people watch the program
Scientology says that Psychiatry is evil
it's a dark nonsense Psychiatry is
simply a very human attempt to help
treat mental illness which is very
difficult but Psychiatry is a good thing
weirdly because of my huge battle with
Scientology science psychiatrists love
me and in 2016 I was invited to the Viv
by Simon Guzman who is the president of
the Ukrainian Psychiatric association by
the way I've got a t-shirt I'm not
wearing it today with Ukrainian
Psychiatric association which I love
wearing on the tube in London and Simeon
is a great friend of mine no I don't
know if you know the story you know the
story of Samuel Simeon was the the first
Soviet psychiatrist he's Ukrainian to
challenge the Soviet abuse of Psychiatry
because they locked up General
gregorenko and he was a great Ukrainian
Soviet Ukrainian General who fought the
Nazis and because he said the Communist
party was corrupt he was locked up in a
psychiatric hospital and given heavy
psychiatric drugs there was nothing
wrong with him
the Communist party was mad he was sane
and semen Guzman wrote a report in 1971
saying this was wrong and he spent 10
years in the KGB prison and the gulag
for this
by the way he is an expert now on the
KGB mindset the mindset of people like
Vladimir puts him and the Ukrainian
governments and I think the Americans of
their anxious what he says but he's my
friend through Scientology so part of my
book to learn the Kremlin is my book is
one of the three people it's dedicated
to is some Englishman
and he said you know remember when I
asked him before that just before the
big Invasion 20 20 seconds something
like this what's with Putin meeting uh
macron you know this long table Yeah and
semian who's very who's a beautiful mind
that says it's the distance between
Vladimir Putin
and his death
very metaphoric but also yeah quite
literal so I know Ukraine and I love it
before the war happened I I didn't spend
enough time here
until until
um February uh last year I came out on
Valentine's Day I've had some bad
Valentine's days in my life I told you
but this one was Bloody awful uh it was
so sad because you all felt you felt
gonna happen you could feel it you know
you know I think it's very interesting
what you said about Walter Durante
Gareth Johns and just overall the
cover-up of all the more because back in
the day like at that time the source of
information could be controlled so
easily that's why stalini had no problem
when like he really didn't have to try
hard to do so so the information doesn't
get out but today we also see the same
like vulture varieties of today we have
journalists who just
for us it feels like living the parallel
reality where they justify Putin's crime
where they talk about the nonsense of
like Western imperialism and like NATO
fighting here almost
and lots of people believe them and also
lots of people people believe with just
like this information in the age where
information is more accessible than ever
why do you think that happens I don't
really understand it and it makes me mad
by the way someone didn't have it all
his own way George Orwell
he he he told the truth and I'm weirdly
Dima um my fixer we were coming back
from her some long drive
um from like a live back to Kiev and he
said you might not want to um
um listen to this audiobook
I said well what is it and he said
Animal Farm
so we listened to George Orwell's Animal
Farm but the stuff there about Squealer
and fake news
I mean what's so weird about it is that
George Orwell has never would not have
heard of Tucker Carlson
but he is the Squealer of the 21st
century he's squealing the Kremlin this
dark nonsense
to what 100 million Americans he's the
Tucker Carlson he's the most popular
American
cable TV host in the United States
what
he talks dark rubbish I'm working on a
film with Vineland TV called Putin's
World War III or third world war do you
want to change in the title but the the
essence of it is to challenge this stuff
do you think there is hope in
challenging that that the minds of those
people who listen to that every day will
change
one day
it's hard
so I'm I've now got
um
it's hard but I you have to be an
optimist you have to believe it but
there are times when it's exhausting
when you you you you you know you like
for example Russia has said it doesn't
Target civilians
well I was in key when they hit the TV
channel I never left you during the
Battle of Key by state and I saw the
police arrive in the morning I was one
of the first reporters to get on the
scene in the morning and I saw the
police remove the dead bodies of an old
man a mother and a five-year-old
daughter I think take them to the morgue
so the idea that Russia doesn't kill
civilians I saw it with my own eyes
um
it it's kind of maddening but this is
true very early on in the war there was
an Indian journalist who told me that
zelenski and Putin were just the same
and my English friends one of whom is a
former Sergeant in the Royal Marines and
a very big man at a physically restrain
me from hitting this idiot because I was
so angry because I was saying that
because I was saying ukrainians died in
front of my eyes or like what
this wall is fake
are you joking some people will even
though and I kind of no it's okay being
British
um it's better being British but
certainly but there are people who
follow me on Twitter who who kind of
guide me and I and what I do is I um I
I'm rude to them and I mute them
um as a policy
and now partly because I I do my daily
Vlogs on Twitter from my Twitter thing
at John Sweeney raw RR I've been
shouting at Scientology but I've now got
280 000 followers
and when I'm rude to one of these people
all my followers say don't bother their
only trolls
but I can't understand the mentality now
the some of them will be
people pay to do this nonsense in Moscow
official Squealers but there are some
people who do it willingly
both on the far left and on the far
right and I just find it a kind of
Madness
and frankly Junior it sickens me you
think it sickens
all of us to experience that denial of
our real experience of all that we see
it's a denial of reality it's a denial
of reality yeah exactly and and and that
there's a kind of what are you doing
what are you talking about do you have a
story that you've covered in Ukraine
during all this time that specifically
stuck with you it really touched you
impacted you may be horrified you I'll
tell you two stories a funny one and a
um and a dark one one of which is why I
love Ukraine one of which is why I hate
Vladimir Putin's Russia day two of the
war I got arrested as a Russian spy
um
by a Ukrainian Soldier do I look like a
Russian spy bang bang bang and there's
no bang bang but you know okay okay okay
and I kept on saying look at my Twitter
picture look at my Twitter picture
um what I told you to stop filming so
this Soldier vladamchenko Vlad said stop
filming and I went yeah yeah walked
another 100 yards and carried on filming
I didn't know that there was a
um a Ukrainian anti-aircraft uh position
and so he was worried I was filming that
everybody was paranoid I was an arrogant
[__] he was
um a bit over the top but I'm more to
blame that's the second day of the war
second day of the day two day two and
and they booked me in to go and see the
um
um Ukrainian intelligence the sbu the
phone call is made and they all talk
about me the Russian spy and I hear it
you know Russia's Bianca yeah
yeah and I go because I did Russian at
school I go I'm not a Russian spy look
me up and then finally they looked me up
and they see the like in 2014 I I
challenge Vladimir Putin
um in a mammoth Museum in Siberia now by
the way it's impossible to challenge
Putin in Moscow because it's Purity will
stop you but he was opening a mammoth
Museum in Siberia and I look like a
professor of mammothology and so I go up
to uh to Putin with all these other
professors and I say what about the
killings in Ukraine what about mh17
um
Furious but Putin all the Russian TV
switch their lights on because they
think the question has been arranged
and so a Britain answers me he talks
rubbish but nevertheless I uh I do so my
Twitter picture is of me challenging
Putin and Vlad looks and they said you
challenge
challenge boosted yes and then he looks
some more on Google and sees that I've
I've annoyed Donald Trump so much Donald
Trump walked out on me
he said this is Donald Trump and yes
I'm not a Russian spy and Brad looks at
me and he says I think you have an
interesting story
I go to the sbu it's a bit heavy but
they check me out they let me go and
then Vlad and I become great friends and
for the
paperback version of my book all half
the money I sold from the paperback
version of this book launch event I had
in queue I gave to blood them check
owners unit he stanked me to Batman five
times every I haven't met him this trip
but every now and then we uh
um we meet and when he's got a break
because he's in special forces in the
Ukrainian Army now but when we meet
um if he's got time off
um we eat and we drink
um we toast to the day he arrested me
for being a Russian spot
beautiful story it's very funny and by
the way the other thing I've got to say
and I need to apologize to everybody in
Ukraine about this is when I met Putin I
was really hungover I've been to my
niece's wedding and I got off the plane
yeah Cuts it's where this moment museum
is nine time zones east of London the
server Eastern Beijing and I'm
desperately hungry no food on the plane
and I say I've got to have a kebab I'm
so hungry and we stop and I eat this
Kebab
um and then I'm waiting for Putin and
then I hit Putin with my question Putin
answers and then this and I'm much
taller than him I'm going to stand up so
I'm like this and he's there and and
Putin is um
um he's he's done and then suddenly I've
got this sense of this Kebab it's gonna
I'm gonna throw up so I should get down
again because I'm changing the picture
angle but I'm gonna throw up over
Vladimir Putin
and
and part of me thinks you know John if
you do throw up over the Vladimir Putin
you'll never have to buy a beer and Kiev
ever again
but I managed to keep it down and I
didn't vomit over the president of
Russia and I and I regret it now and I
apologize thank you I regret not seeing
that recorded live as well three hours
later there was a second event Putin was
doing with the Chinese Deputy Prime
Minister opening a pipeline thing
somewhere in the same kind of place and
Putin and the Chinese official
we're on the stage and it was about 200
yards away it's a great big Hall and
somebody came up to me punch me in the
stomach completely silent but
and walked off I we didn't like your
question Mr Sweeney
no one said anything
um and I was by the time I'd recovered
he's gone
but that's what it's like asking a
question of the master of the Kremlin
the other day I went to Hearthstone
police station
and um
we interviewed a with actually there
were two places one was the new cells
and there was a lovely Ukrainian guy
called Sasha and he spoke about being
tortured with the phone which is where
they wind up a hand-cranked military
fuel foam and take the phone off and
they put the clips on your ears when
your fingers and toes and they shock you
yeah but you can't move because your
hands are tied behind your back and the
poor fellow Sasha cried was taking us
around us in the Spanish TV crew
then we went to a second place which was
these were Soviet era cells underneath
the main police station in Herson
and it was really dark and damp and in
the
um in the basement
we found some
elephants
Sloan do you know what they are
the slum the elephant and Russian is the
nickname for the Soviet era gas mask
a long green face with a big things and
then you have the corrugated trunk the
breathing tube looks like an elephant's
trunk and then it goes into a um a
filter
filter had been disconnected the trunk
was gone that the gas masks were there
and I first came across this in 23 years
ago in chechnya when I did the radio
documentary for the BBC about the
Russian army torture injections and what
they did was they were Thai people
behind their backs put the gas mask on
the face
and then they the particular refinement
they did in chechnya was they would
squirt CS gas up the nozzle
into the gas mask
so people would start drowning on their
own tears
um
so when I saw these gas masks in person
it triggered memory of that and then I
went looking at the moment I hadn't been
able to find any person
um torture victims who'd been
um tortured with that mask but it is
true they've been using it um in Ukraine
and the there's a police detective in
Islam who told by fixed fix edema that
they've used the gas mask the elephant
in ISM against ukrainians before it was
liberated what matters here is not the
individual methods
the elephant or the phone
but the pattern
and the pattern has been going for 23
years
massive use of torture on a massive
scale it's a pattern and it's a system
and it's part of Vladimir Putin system
of keeping control keeping power
through violence do you think it's been
discussed enough in Western media
um
dark
but when I saw this mask I did them I
first saw this in 23 years ago it's a
mass you get tortured
you can there are variance of it you
just squeeze the two and then the victim
can't breathe after two minutes they
lose Consciousness you open it up and
then you do it on repeat I think Schultz
is getting better but certainly it's
true to say that people like president
macron and France and Chancellor Schultz
of Germany at the start of the big war
wanted Ukraine to do some kind of
bad peace deal with Russia
and my problem with that is you're not
dealing with a normal politician you're
dealing with a psychopath I don't think
Vladimir Putin is a killer I think he's
a serial killer you cannot do a deal
with someone like that his use of
torture is systemic
his use of of crimes against humanity
bombing blocks of flats into knee Pro we
saw the the block of plant in January we
can look at people's kitchen you can
look at people's kitchen attachments and
their bathroom stuff
as if it's some awful horror show no
it's real the violence against women as
well with various and rape on a massive
scale and also castration much rarer but
it does happen of Ukrainian soldiers
so I want to say to some of the people
in the west would you like to be
castrated
is that you know because that's that's
what Vladimir Putin wants from the
ukrainians right he wants
um he I mean I'm uncomfortable because
I'm because of my age I'm uncomfortable
with using the word genocide because I
was brought up when it specifically
meant
something like the mass murder of the
Jews but the meaning has become broader
but in terms of destroying what Ukraine
and Ukrainian means in terms of culture
and literature all of that you just go
to Hearthstone
um police station and you've seen
they've shot books about Ukraine written
by Ukrainian patients they've shot them
so like how do you talk to people who do
this stuff who rape and constraint who
who kill children
very few people actually know that the
term genocide which was coined by
Raphael M King who did a lot of history
research on Holden Warren specifically
what Soviets were doing in Ukraine
it was so it was coined because of the
holiday Mall not because but it was one
of the examples that he used as well
um he has a book I think that says on
genocide and I've studied it in the
university and I was really surprised
that he actually he came to do
researcher studies in the view uh
Raphael wanking and when the resolution
U.N resolution on genocide was signed I
think the Soviets were not really happy
of them being in any way mentioned or
connected to that so obviously when you
look at the definitions of genocide
anything like holiday more can be kind
of disputed because it's not that
explicit you can it was it happened yeah
so that's why there's still this debate
where the whether Voldemort was genocide
or not well it's clearly it was yes so
holiday more was genocide and what's
happening now is genocide and we've got
to say to the Russians racer game you've
got it like I I'm you know I did
Russians school I don't speak it at all
well but there was a time in my life
when I loved all things Russian no more
um I met I mispronounced everybody's
names but Anna politics
a politkovskaya she was the Russian
journalist who was first poisoned she
survived then shot dead in 2006 and she
warned in 2003 that Vladimir Putin by by
um destroying free media in Russia was
zombifying Russia
and she was right and Putin has
succeeded in zombified Russia I also
knew
uh so annapositive Sky Natasha esmerova
Burson himself
in order poison then shot shot shot
poisoned now in jail now I know many
ukrainians don't like navalny because he
said some idiotic things and they were
apologized but he is
the greatest enemy of Putin in Russia
um I've met him twice
and he says this war is wrong and it
should stop and about that is rights and
about that I agree with about me do you
think there is actually hope that
somebody can come after Putin who's not
just you know more successful in
fighting corruption which is what Nevada
claims he is but
the same way imperialist and also
xenophobic yes he um it ends when
Russia leaves Ukraine
and I think the only way that happens is
when the Ukrainian Army defeats Russia
and then I'm hoping somebody
gets rid of Putin I put um
a fiver on deripaska because he's such a
gangster he actually might have a go at
Putin but Putin's War has been a
catastrophe for Russia and what they
don't understand is that Russia when
they lose this war and they will lose
this war but Russia
will stand in shame as Germany stood in
shame after the horrors of the Nazi
regime became obvious to everyone
everywhere but what they need to do is
like Willie Brandt the West German
leader he went to the Warsaw Ghetto and
he kneeled because he was genuinely
sorry about what had happened what his
Nation had done and the Russians need to
do that I think for us ukrainians it's
really hard to imagine that because
Russians have been committing repeatedly
genocide's genocides after John said and
never reflected in the way that is a
great friend of Ukraine my anxiety would
be that if you tell the West that we're
locked into a Perpetual war with Russia
people will go crikey
and and get afraid of that and every now
and then so I'm an optimist you can call
me a fool
um but when Russia loses War
uh loses the wall it can get better so
after it lost the Crimea War
um they abandoned serfdom after they
lost the war against the Japanese they
created a parliament in zuma
I'm hoping after they lose this war they
become a sweet liberal democracy and uh
and some of the United States I'm an
optimist but call me a fool I think a
lot of Ukraine is hoping for
disintegration of Russia and the
liberation of currently occupied
territories such as chechnya and other
which is something very uncomfortable
for the West because
it's scary but so the Americans in
particular are afraid of this so the
problem that the Americans have got in
particular is a fear of Iraq 2.0
but if you get rid of Putin you won't
have a nice liberal Democrat you won't
even have no baloney
um who's a Democrat with
with a troubled history Brave man though
he is you will have chaos
and the possibility for example of an
islamist chechnya getting hold of a
nuclear weapon
and so the gossip in Washington DC is
that the Americans want a Ukrainian
Victory but on November the 5th next
year November 4th being the date of the
American presidential election they
don't want the ukrainians to win too
quickly because if they win too quickly
then your Putin will fall and then
there'll be chaos
that's the goal let's spill more
Ukrainian blood
no the the counter argument is that
actually it looks bad if Russia does
better
and and I'm torn about it but
I was very excited when Joe Biden
came to keep by the way
um so when my book is like killer in the
Kremlin it's got a picture of Vladimir
Putin on it
um and it basically it's like a Harry
Potter letter I can get through anything
any checkpoint I've written this book I
get arrested you get detained by mistake
or I haven't got the right paper
paperwork in this particular old glass
whatever and I'm used to it it's kind of
my hobby being arrested but then they I
show my book and then it's fine on you
go and then there's this massive
Security in the heart of Kiev and I want
to go somewhere and I take my book out
and the Ukrainian cop said no go back
and I thought that's Biden because
nothing else would cause Ukrainian
policemen to say that um to an author of
A Book Like Mine and um
and and I said on Twitter word is it's
Biden and I called it an hour before the
BBC
you're the first one yeah
it's been incredibly into
feel like we can talk and even
different topics for people a few more
hours or forever exactly
um either way it's a it's a pleasure to
learn about your experience but I also
wanted to ask you probably as a very
experienced journalist reporter
investigator I think I'm the oldest one
or one of the oldest that are here
currently yeah yeah so Ukraine I mean
has been Ukraine and Russian the region
of Ukraine has been a very hot topic
so-called now the media attention kind
of like a little bit dies down
especially like with all the turmoil
happening in the west and people just
shifting Focus which is I guess normal
yet
um sad for us but still lots of
journalists come and go
um this term parachute journalism you
know when they just come here and do
like a quick Story come back go back to
whatever country they're coming from
what do you
recommend or what kind of advice would
you give to journalists who are coming
to Ukraine for the first time now
specifically Western journalists
what should they do to prepare to cover
what kind of maybe do's and don'ts it's
a huge country what is the biggest in
Europe
um I don't think Russia's in Europe
anymore
um it's a huge country and it takes you
time to do stuff but time here is
beautifully rewarded it is a ravishingly
beautiful country full of incredibly
funny people
um I love the Ukrainian sense of humor
which is as I mean you know as a Brit
it's very very British
um very very English it's very dark but
there's a wonderful sense of which
um and and
there are moments where you
were you kind of there are moments of
humor and courage and resilience which
is which are extraordinarily beautiful
in the worst of times
the best that people come come out and
and you see it again and again like you
see it on Twitter but you see it in real
life as well of people being brave and
good and kind being in Ukraine telling
helping to tell the story of ordinary
extraordinary ukrainians has been the
great pride of the sunset of my
journalistic career and and
um what a story of courage and heroism
that one of the things I love about cube
is
I'm listening I'm old but I'm not that
old
um but
um
one I read about London in 1940 feels
like Keys now I all everybody wants to
do is drink beer and go dancing but you
have to fight the monster and then when
you read about these tremendous sort of
drinking sessions in SoHo as the bombers
were falling and and there would be bars
where people would play jazz of course
banned by the Nazis people would play
Chance in London under the bombs
and
all people wanted to do was have fun and
love life and live life they had to
fight the monster and that's exactly
what you're doing all you want to do and
there's my friend Vlad them checo says
Ukraine is like the Shire and Lord of
the Rings well Hobbits all we want to do
is go dancing and drink beer but you
have to fight the monster so I would say
to um especially young journalists
um
it's
certainly hanging out in Kiev is much
safer than you might imagine it to be if
you go to the war zone you need to you
do need to go on a hostile environment
course the Frontline Club is running one
um at low little cost
um in Kiev right now but you do need to
take a tourniquet you do need to know
how to use it because
um sometimes it rains shells sometimes
it's downpour of Russian Artillery but
nevertheless
this is an extraordinary story and come
and tell it and for how long do you hope
to cover it
um until
I die or Vladimir Putin die
I hope
yeah
[Laughter]
well thank you so much thank you for the
work you're doing and for having such a
almost intimate relationship with
Ukraine and reporting on the courage of
ukrainians and on the crimes and the
horrific violence of Russians the other
piece of advice
um to um
British or anyway any foreign journalist
coming here you need to if you're
British you need to know two phrases
Putin who which means Putin's Institute
yes certainly last year God Save the
Queen you can get through most Ukrainian
checkpoints after after curfew if you
just go hello good evening God Save the
Queen Putin who and they go you're late
but go away
so that that's the that's the Sweeney
tip for how to get through the Ukrainian
Army checkpoints after curfew well
that's great I hope journalists use it
but don't abuse it
it was just it happened once or twice
yeah well thank you so much uh we had a
great conversation with John Sweeney if
you like this video video please
subscribe to Ukraine's Channel and check
out more stories on our website